Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. The centre of Constantinople had been left gutted. Among the many treasures destroyed in the inferno had been the Senate House
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告畅听并进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。君士坦丁堡的市中心已被烧得满目疮痍。在大火中摧毁的众多珍宝中，有元老院大楼
and all the antique statues with which Constantine had long previously adorned the bathhouse. Their loss had obliterated precious links with what was by now a very distant past. Yet in truth, Justinian was pleased to see them gone. The Senate House had always loomed too large over the Augustaeon for his tastes. Its replacement, so he decreed, was to be built on a much smaller scale. The monuments that Justinian aimed to found upon the rubble of the old would be raised to the glory not of the traditional gods of the roman people but of something very different a single omnipotent god tom who who wrote that
以及君士坦丁曾经用来装饰浴室的各种古代雕像。它们的遗失抹去了与这个本已十分遥远的过去的珍贵联系。然而事实上，查士丁尼很高兴看到它们消失。按照他的品味，元老院大楼在奥古斯塔广场上的存在感总是太强了。正如他所下令的那样，它的替代建筑将以小得多的规模建造。查士丁尼旨在在这片旧日废墟上建立的纪念碑，将不是为了罗马人民的传统神灵的荣耀而升起，而是为了一个截然不同的存在——一个全能的单一神明。汤姆，谁写了那篇
deathless prose uh it was a top historian as yourself it was yes it was um so that's in the shadow of the sword um and that is just a summary of where we were at the end of last episode. Yeah, we're back with Justin and Theodore, aren't we? The third episode of what was going to be one episode. So for those people who haven't listened to the previous two, obviously you do need to listen. Well, you don't need to, but you could and you should listen to the previous two. We're in the 6th century.
不朽的散文？呃，那可是一位顶尖的历史学家，也就是你。是的，没错。嗯，那是出自《剑影之下》；而那只是上一集结束时我们所处境况的总结。是的，我们又回到了查士丁尼和狄奥多拉的故事，对吧？本来打算做一集，现在已经是第三集了。所以对于那些没有听过前两集的人，显然你们需要去听。嗯，其实不是非听不可，但你们可以也应该去听听前两集。我们正处于公元6世纪。
We're in Constantinople, the new rome the capital of the well you call it the roman empire the eastern roman empire the byzantine empire um this incredibly glamorous couple are emperor and empress justinian and theodora they have just seen off the blues and the greens the circus factions who are rioting at the beginning of 532 they justinian has is rebuilding Hagia Sophia, the great church of the holy wisdom, the great cathedral that still is one of the world's great sort of tourist sites in the center of Istanbul. And Tom, Justinian, I mean, the paradox of Justinian, as you say, is that he seems to us to mark a break with ancient Rome, because conventionally,
我们正身处君士坦丁堡，新罗马，也就是——你可以称之为罗马帝国、东罗马帝国、拜占庭帝国——的首都。这对极其光鲜亮丽的夫妇就是皇帝查士丁尼和皇后狄奥多拉。他们刚刚平息了蓝党和绿党的骚乱，也就是532年初暴动的那群赛马场派别。查士丁尼正在重建圣索菲亚大教堂，这座伟大的圣智教堂，至今仍是伊斯坦布尔市中心世界级的旅游胜地之一。汤姆，查士丁尼……我的意思是，正如你所说，查士丁尼的悖论在于，在我们看来，他似乎标志着与古代罗马的决裂，因为按照常规，
I suppose, in kind of popular history books, in textbooks and encyclopedias and things, the 6th century is roughly the point at which people stop talking of this as the Roman Empire, and they start talking of it as the Byzantine Empire. But Justinian has this project, doesn't he, to rebuild not just the city, but to rebuild the Roman world by reuniting Constantinople with Italy and with North Africa and perhaps ultimately with Spain, who knows, with Gaul, with Britain even, with the provinces that have been lost. that we ended our last episode on this note, that Justinian is an incredibly paradoxical figure, because on the one hand, he seems almost a bit of an anachronism. He is a kind of Caesar of the order of Trajan. He's a great conqueror. He's the embodiment of these kind of ancient roman martial imperial traditions but at the same time his attempts to kind of restore this roman empire actually precipitates its decline yeah well that's the big that's the big argument isn't it about whether that's the case but actually when it
我想，在通俗历史书、教科书、百科全书之类的内容中，6世纪大致是人们不再称其为罗马帝国，而开始称其为拜占庭帝国的时间节点。但查士丁尼有一个宏伟的项目，不是吗？不仅要重建这座城市，还要通过将君士坦丁堡与意大利、北非重新联合，或许最终与西班牙联合，谁知道呢，还有高卢、甚至不列颠，与那些已经失去的行省联合，来重建罗马世界。我们在上一集结束时曾得出这样的结论：查士丁尼是一个极其矛盾的人物，因为一方面，他看起来几乎有点不合时宜。他是一位图拉真级别的凯撒。他是一位伟大的征服者。他是古代罗马尚武帝国传统的化身，但与此同时，他恢复这个罗马帝国的企图实际上促成了它的衰落。是的，好吧，这就是那个巨大的争议，对吧？关于这到底是不是真的，但实际上，当它
starts so he starts with north Africa, doesn't he? That's his first target. And it's a relatively, it's been run by these, I mean, it's been taken over by these people called the Vandals for about 100 years. And actually that campaign goes pretty well. The Vandals, interestingly, we haven't talked as much as some people might expect about Christological disputes. But the Vandals are yet another brand of heretics because they are Aryans, aren't they?
开始时，他是从北非开始的，不是吗？那是他的第一个目标。那里由一群被称为汪达尔人的人统治了大约100年。实际上，那场战役进展得相当顺利。有趣的是，汪达尔人——我们并没有像某些人预期那样多地谈论基督论之争——但汪达尔人又是另一种异端，因为他们是阿里乌派，对吧？
So they believe. Now, Tom, I know you'll think this is a grotesque simplification, but am I right in thinking the Vandals believe that Jesus is subordinate to God? Basically, yes. He's not co-eternal with God. He's not quite as good. And so in the first episode we talked about these kind of rows about the nature of christ and at the arian heresy that the vandals hold to um is a product of the fourth century the age of constantine so in that sense
所以他们坚信……汤姆，我知道你会觉得这是一种极其粗暴的简化，但我这样认为对吗：汪达尔人相信耶稣从属于上帝？基本上是的。他不是与上帝共存恒久的。他没有那么完美。所以在第一集中，我们讨论了这些关于基督本质的争论，而汪达尔人所坚守的阿里乌派异端，是4世纪君士坦丁时代的产物，所以从这个意义上说，
the vandals are you know they're throwbacks they're theological throwbacks cranky they're dinosaurs they are done yeah so they've clearly Clearly, they've got to be cleared up. The Vandals are doubly a threat because they're occupying the breadbasket that had previously fed Rome. They're occupying the great Roman city of Carthage. But also,
汪达尔人你知道的，他们是复古派，是神学上的复古派，冥顽不灵，他们就像恐龙，已经被淘汰了。是的，所以他们显然……很显然，他们必须被清除。汪达尔人构成了双重威胁，因为他们占领了以前供给罗马的粮仓。他们占领了伟大的罗马城市迦太基。但同时，
they hold to this kind of antiquated heresy and it's unacceptable. So Justinian raises an immense fleet, a great armada. It sails out from the harbour of Constantinople to much cheering. And it's a triumph of success and it's under the command of Belisarius, who people who listened to the previous episode may remember is very much in Justinian's good books
他们信奉这种陈旧过时的异端，这是不可接受的。因此，查士丁尼组建了一支庞大的舰队，一支伟大的无敌舰队。它在阵阵欢呼声中从君士坦丁堡港口起航。这是一场圆满的胜利，由贝利撒留指挥。听过上一集的人可能还记得，贝利撒留在查士丁尼心目中的印象非常好，
because he's slaughtered thousands of people in the hippodrome the equivalents of loads of unarmed football hooligans exactly yes but so so actually when you look at the timeline i mean the fleet leaves in the midsummer 533 so that's just over a year we're a year and a bit since the the end of the rioting um but actually they pretty much wiped the floor with the vandals within less than a year so that the the king of the vandals is a man called gelima do you know what happened to gelima tom he gets taken back doesn't he and led to triumph so he was beaten at a battle gelima went and hid and uh belisarius said you know will you surrender and he said yes and you know what he asked for in return i'm so delighted i found these details of the same remind me he said, yes. And do you know what he asked for in return? I'm so delighted I found these details.
因为他在竞技场里屠杀了数千人，这就相当于一大群手无寸铁的足球流氓，完全是的。但实际上，当你看看时间线时——舰队是在533年盛夏出发的——那距离暴乱结束刚刚过去了一年多，我们处于骚乱结束一年多的时间点。但实际上，他们在不到一年的时间里就把汪达尔人打得落花流水。汪达尔人的国王是一个名叫盖利摩的人。你知道盖利摩后来怎么了吗，汤姆？他被带了回去，对吧？被押去进行凯旋式。所以他在一场战役中被打败了，盖利摩躲了起来，然后贝利撒留说：“你会投降吗？”他说：“会的。”你知道他要求什么回报吗？我太高兴我找到了这些细节……提醒我一下。他说：“是的。你知道他要求什么回报吗？我太高兴我找到了这些细节。”
No, remind me. He said, I require just two things to get me to surrender. They were a sponge and a liar. The sponge was to wipe his eye because he suffered an eye infection while in hiding. And the liar was, Gelimer had written a song. He'd written a dirge because he felt very downbeat after losing his kingdom and he said i'd like a liar so that i could i could try it out so belisarius gave him that so he gave him the sponge and the liar he was taken to constantinople in and he was led in a
不，提醒我一下。他说：“我投降只需要两样东西。它们是一块海绵和一个里拉琴。”海绵是用来擦拭他的眼睛的，因为他在躲藏时患上了眼疾；里拉琴是因为盖利摩写过一首歌。他写了一首挽歌，因为他在失去王国后感到非常沮丧，他说我想要一把里拉琴，这样我就可以试弹一下。于是贝利撒留给了他这些东西，他给了他海绵和里拉琴，他被带到了君士坦丁堡，并被押送着进行了一场
triumph so that's very roman tom unbelievably roman yeah so this great triumph that kind of culminates in the uh in the hippod And he retired. Golema retired. He was allowed to retire to Galatia. Galatia is now in Turkey, I think, is it? Yeah. So it's kind of middle of Cappadocia. So is he in danger of getting a letter from St. Paul? Did St. Paul write to the Galatians?
凯旋式。所以这非常罗马，汤姆，简直不可思议地罗马。是的，这场伟大的凯旋式在竞技场中达到了高潮。他退隐了。盖利摩退休了。他被允许退居加拉太。加拉太现在在土耳其，我想，是吗？是的。所以它有点像卡帕多西亚的中部。那么他有没有收到保罗书信的危险呢？圣保罗给加拉太人写过信吗？
Yes, he did. So am I right in thinking, therefore, the Vandal rule in Africa must have been relatively kind of shallow? Yeah, pretty much. They were disliked by the people that they ruled. Is that because they're basically a bunch of Germans kind of sweating in the African sun? The dark reputation that they have is reflected in the fact that we still use the word Vandal to mean what it means. And the story is that they took the looted treasures from Jerusalem that Titus had brought in the first century, paraded in his triumph through the streets of Rome, that the vandals then took it to Carthage
是的，他写过。所以我这样想对吗？因此，汪达尔人在非洲的统治一定相对来说比较肤浅？是的，差不多。他们不受他们统治的人民的欢迎。这是因为他们基本上是一群在非洲阳光下挥汗如雨的日耳曼人吗？他们那黑暗的名声体现在我们至今仍然使用“汪达尔人”（Vandal）这个词来指代它现在的含义。传说是这样的：他们拿走了提图斯在公元一世纪从耶路撒冷带回并在罗马街头的凯旋式上游行的战利品，汪达尔人随后把它们带到了迦太基，
and Belisarius then takes them to Constantinople is one of the story. We're not absolutely sure about that, but if that's true, it's kind of a nice sense of the way, which is very good story. You know, these are the trophies of victory and Justinian could legitimately say, well,
而贝利撒留随后又把它们带到了君士坦丁堡，这就是其中一个传说。我们对此并不百分之百确定，但如果这是真的，它确实有一种奇妙的感觉，这是一个非常精彩的故事。你知道，这些是胜利的战利品，查士丁尼可以合情合理地说：“嗯，
you know, Rome is back. We're celebrating triumphs. And of course the next target is the big one, which is Italy and Rome, but that's a different matter, isn't it? So Italy is,
你知道，罗马回来了。我们在庆祝凯旋。”当然，下一个目标就是重中之重，也就是意大利和罗马，但这又是另一回事了，对吧？所以意大利是，
um, has been run by the Goths, the Ostrogoths. Theoderic, who had been the great Gothic leader, had sort of been subordinate to Constantinople. Am I right? He'd sort of acknowledged the kind of suzerainty of the emperor in Constantinople? Yeah. So there's a kind of spacious legalism whereby the emperor could pretend that he still ruled Italy and the Ostrogoths could pretend that he still ruled italy and the ostrogoths could feel that they had a you know that they'd been legitimized that they weren't just kind of barbarians yeah and italy italy under theodoric is a pretty stable prosperous place
呃，一直由哥特人、东哥特人统治。曾是伟大的哥特人领袖的狄奥多里克，某种程度上从属于君士坦丁堡。我说的对吗？他某种程度上承认了君士坦丁堡皇帝的宗主权？是的。所以存在一种宽泛的法律主义，皇帝可以假装他仍然统治着意大利，东哥特人也可以假装他仍然统治着意大利，东哥特人可以觉得他们拥有——你知道的——他们被合法化了，他们不仅仅是某种野蛮人。是的，狄奥多里克统治下的意大利是一个相当稳定、繁荣的地方。
so they are you know the senate is still sitting in rome chariots are still being raised in circus maximus um water is flowing happily along the aqueducts so you know there are lots of people Senate is still sitting in Rome. Chariots are still being raised in Circus Maximus. Water is flowing happily along the aqueducts. So, you know, there are lots of people, I think we mentioned this in the episode we did on when the Roman Empire falls, that I think there are lots of people in Italy who don't particularly feel that the Roman Empire has fallen. And to that extent, the arrival of a large flotilla
所以他们——你知道，元老院仍然在罗马开会，竞技场里仍然在举行战车赛，水流仍然欢快地沿着高架渠流淌。所以，你知道，有很多人……元老院仍然在罗马开会。竞技场里仍然在举行战车赛。水流仍然欢快地沿着高架渠流淌。所以，你知道，有很多人——我想我们在关于罗马帝国灭亡的那期节目中提到过这一点——我认为意大利有很多人并不特别觉得罗马帝国已经灭亡了。从这个意义上说，一支庞大的舰队从君士坦丁堡抵达，
from Constantinople isn't necessarily greeted with fractious enthusiasm, because it means that Italy will now become a theatre of war. Well, I was going to ask about this, because we could, I mean, we could spend, I mean, do a sort of Dan Carlin hardcore history style narrative of the Italian wars. I actually, I mean, I studied these when I was a student. And when I used to read Procopius' account of the wars in Italy, I found it absolutely impossible to keep awake, let alone to work out what was going on. But basically, it's cut a really, really long story,
不一定受到狂热的欢迎，因为这意味着意大利现在将成为一个战区。嗯，我正要问这个，因为我们本来可以——我的意思是我们可以花时间，搞一段丹·卡林式的硬核历史风格的意大利战争叙事。实际上，我的意思是，当我还是个学生的时候，我学过这些。当我读到普罗科匹乌斯对意大利战争的记述时，我发现它绝对让人无法保持清醒，更不用说弄清楚发生了什么了。但基本上，长话短说，
very, very simplistically short. The campaign just lasts forever. And I mean, within a year of landing, so Belisarius is in charge yet again. He captures Naples. But within a year of landing, so Belisarius is in charge yet again. He captures Naples. But within a year of landing, he's basically holed up in Rome, isn't he? He's got into Rome. Yeah, so Belisarius famously is the first person to capture Rome from the south before the Allies in the Second World War.
用极其简单的方式缩短：这场战役没完没了。我的意思是，在登陆的一年内——贝利撒留再次负责——他攻占了那不勒斯。但在登陆的一年内——贝利撒留再次负责——他攻占了那不勒斯。但在登陆的一年内，他基本上被困在罗马了，不是吗？他进入了罗马。是的，所以贝利撒留大名鼎鼎，他是二战盟军之前第一个从南部攻占罗马的人。
So your brother has written a book about the war in Italy in the Second World War. And I was struck because everyone always says, you know, the war in Italy is sort of the forgotten part of the Second World War because it was so vicious and so difficult for the Allies fighting their way up the peninsula against the Germans. And there's a bit of an element of that about this, isn't there? A bit, yeah. They've had a sort of a soft start in North Africa, and now they land in Italy, and it's just so much more difficult.
所以你哥哥写了一本关于第二次世界大战中意大利战争的书。我印象深刻，因为每个人总是说，你知道，意大利战争是第二次世界大战中被遗忘的一部分，因为对盟军来说，沿半岛向上推进与德国人作战是如此残酷和艰难。这件事也有点这方面的成分，不是吗？有点，是的。他们在北非有了一个相对轻松的开局，现在他们登陆意大利，情况却变得艰难得多。
And yeah, Belisarius does capture Rome, but then he ends up- He loses it, gets it back. And this is essentially what finishes Rome off as a great capital. Because during the course of all these kind of sieges and so on, the aqueducts get cut. And without the aqueducts, it becomes impossible to sustain the size of population that rome had had and at one point during these wars rome effectively becomes
是的，贝利撒留确实攻占了罗马，但他最终——他又失去了它，又夺回了它。这基本上就是终结罗马作为伟大首都命运的原因。因为在所有这些围城战等等的过程中，高架渠被切断了。没有了高架渠，就无法维持罗马曾经拥有的人口规模，而在这些战争中的某个时刻，罗马实际上变得
depopulated so the city that at the heyday of the empire had had a million you know it's it's this absolute wilderness it's this emptied wilderness i mean that's true of much of italy isn't it that the farmlands are destroyed by these armies crisscrossing back and forth you get accounts of people starving. It must have been a kind of apocalyptic landscape. Completely. And, you know, thanks first to Belisarius and then to Narses, who by this point is about 310.
荒无人烟。所以这座在帝国全盛时期拥有一百万人口的城市，你知道的——它变成了一片绝对的荒野，变成了一片空荡荡的荒野。我的意思是，意大利的大部分地区都是如此，不是吗？农田被这些来回穿梭的军队摧毁了。你会听到人们挨饿的记载。那一定是一种末日般的景象。完全是。而且，你知道，首先多亏了贝利撒留，然后是纳尔塞斯，到这个时候他大概已经310岁了……
Yeah. So he takes over the command. They effectively get control of Italy, but it's, you know, it's a charnel house. And if you want to say, well, when does the Roman Empire end in Italyaly i'd say it's with this i mean i know it's impossible to say but is it your sense that most people in italy would have much preferred the in inverted commas roman army never to have pitched up and to just lived quite happily under
是的。所以他接管了指挥权。他们实际上控制了意大利，但你知道，这是一个尸横遍野的屠宰场。如果你想说，嗯，罗马帝国究竟是什么时候在意大利灭亡的？我会说是这个时候。我的意思是，我知道这很难说，但你是否觉得意大利的大多数人其实更希望所谓的罗马军队从来没有出现过，而宁愿在哥特人的统治下过着相当快乐的生活？是的，当然。我的意思是，你知道，如果你是罗马的元老，而你最终变成了一个身无分文的难民，那么由君士坦丁堡的一位凯撒皇帝来统治你，根本算不上什么安慰。是的，当然。最糟糕的是，你知道，从身无分文的元老的角度来看，这一切都是白费力气。因为就在征服似乎刚刚完成、哥特人被打败后不久，以伦巴第人形式出现的一支全新的人民出现了，
gothic rule yeah of course i mean you know if you're if you're're a senator in Rome, and you end up a penniless refugee, it's no consolation that you are now ruled by an emperor from a Caesar in Constantinople. Yeah, of course. And the worst thing is that, you know, from the point of view of the penniless senator, is that it's all for nothing. Because very soon after the conquests have seemingly been completed, and the Gothss defeated a whole new people in the form of the lombards turn up yeah and grab you know huge chunks of italy so that um constantinople ends up ruling rome still so it still has rome and it has ravenna because ravenna
并且占领了意大利的大片土地，以至于君士坦丁堡最终仍然统治着罗马——所以它仍然拥有罗马，而且它拥有拉韦纳，因为拉韦纳是一个向开往亚得里亚海的船只开放的港口，而且拉韦纳以前也是一个帝国首都，不是吗？是的。所以那里有很多宫殿。那里有很多教堂。它曾经几乎是东哥特统治的首都。它将成为查士丁尼和狄奥多拉最著名的视觉形象所在地。嗯，这就是我正要说的，汤姆，从游客的角度来看，从现代游客的角度来看，这些战争非常值得，因为这些关于查士丁尼和狄奥多拉的非凡视觉描绘幸存了下来，在——我想是在拉韦纳的圣维塔莱教堂里，对吧？我的意思是，它们是最不可思议的拜占庭马赛克。但是，你知道，这稍微把我们带回了查士丁尼和狄奥多拉的个性上，
is a port that is is open to shipping coming up the adriatic and ravenna had been a previous imperial capital as well hadn't it it had yes And so there are lots of palaces there. There are lots of churches there. It had been pretty much the capital for Austro-Gothic rule. And it will become the place where the most famous visual representations of Justinian Theodora. Well, this is what I was about to say, Tom, that the wars from a tourist's perspective, from a modern tourist's perspective, the wars were tremendously worthwhile because these extraordinary visual depictions of Justinian and Theodora survive in the church of, I think it's San Vitale, isn't it, in Ravenna. I mean, they are the most incredible Byzantine mosaics. But, you know, that brings us slightly back to the personalities of Justinian and Theodora which i guess sometimes get lost in this story because we have images of them that we don't have really of most other post-sixth century
我想这些个性有时在这个故事中被遗忘了，因为我们拥有关于他们的图像，而对于大多数其他6世纪之后的
um emperors and certainly empresses i guess do you think that's one reason why another reason why theodora is i mean nobody really remembers any barely any maybe zoe later on really irene yeah but apart from that nobody remembers other empresses do you think that the existence I mean, nobody really remembers any, barely any, maybe Zoe later on. Irene, perhaps. Irene, yeah. But apart from that, nobody remembers other empresses. Do you think that the existence of the mosaics is one reason why? Yes, I'm sure. Because, you know, the literal iconography of it, it's so powerful. And they're such kind of stunning mosaics.
皇帝——当然还有女皇——我们真的没有。你认为这是另一个原因吗？另一个原因是为什么狄奥多拉——我的意思是，没有人真正记得任何——几乎没有人，也许后来的佐伊真的记得，伊琳娜，是的，但除此之外，没有人记得其他女皇。你认为马赛克的存在是一个原因吗？是的，我确信。因为，你知道的，它的字面图像学，它是如此强大。而且它们是如此惊人的马赛克。
They're on the cover of every book about, not just Justinian Theodora, but about pretty much Byzantium. Well, I think because they're completely worth it and a tremendous idea because they gave us the mosaics that we can advertise this podcast with. However, just after they've embarked, really, I mean, within a year or a couple of years of embarking on this reconquest of Italy, there's trouble in the East. So we've talked in previous episodes about Persia being the big superpower threat to Constantinople and Khosrow as sort of, is he Khrushchev to Justinian's Kennedy or is he Kennedy to Justinian's Khrushchev? I don't know who quite fits that analogy. I mean, Justinian is a peasant stock, isn't he?
它们出现在每一本关于——不仅是查士丁尼和狄奥多拉，而且几乎是关于整个拜占庭——的书的封面上。嗯，我认为因为它们完全值得，而且是个了不起的主意，因为它们为我们提供了马赛克，我们可以用它来宣传这个播客。然而，就在他们开始——真的，在开始重新征服意大利的一年或几年内——东方传来了麻烦。所以我们在之前的节目中讨论过，波斯是君士坦丁堡的主要超级大国威胁，而霍斯劳就像是查士丁尼的肯尼迪的赫鲁晓夫，还是查士丁尼的赫鲁晓夫的肯尼迪？我不知道谁真正符合这个类比。我的意思是，查士丁尼出身农民家庭，不是吗？
So maybe he's Khrushchev. And Khosrow is a very regal stock. So maybe he's Kennedy. Anyway, the Persians reappear, come across the frontier, and they basically capture Antioch. Which is the third city. So it's in Syria. It's the great capital of Syria.
所以也许他是赫鲁晓夫。而霍斯劳出身非常高贵的血统。所以也许他是肯尼迪。无论如何，波斯人再次出现，越过边境，他们基本上攻占了安条克。也就是第三大城市。所以它在叙利亚。它是叙利亚伟大的首都。
Very ancient city, very rich city. So it's in Syria. It's the great capital of Syria, very ancient city, very rich city. So it's a disaster. So Procopius says, I become dizzy as I write of such a great calamity. And that must have been how many people in Constantinople felt when they contemplated the fact. I mean, it's a problem for them that Antioch is not that far from the border, I suppose. And as you said in previous episodes, there are no real natural frontiers between Rome and Persia, so that the Persians can just, you know, if they spot a weakness, they can just pile across. But this is a colossal setback for Justinian.
非常古老的城市，非常富有的城市。所以它在叙利亚。它是叙利亚伟大的首都，非常古老的城市，非常富有的城市。所以这是一场灾难。因此普罗科匹乌斯说：当我写到如此巨大的灾难时，我感到一阵眩晕。君士坦丁堡的许多人在思考这个事实时，一定也是这种感觉。我的意思是，对他们来说，安条克离边境不太远是个问题，我想。正如你在前几集里所说的那样，罗马和波斯之间没有真正的天然国界，所以波斯人只要——你知道的——如果他们发现弱点，他们就可以直接大举入侵。但这对于查士丁尼来说是一个巨大的挫折。
Surely a bigger setback than the capture of some of Italy is a triumph. Do you think? Yeah, definitely. It's a humiliation and it's a stunning blow to the economy of the empire. Yeah. To have your third city, to have all the skilled people, all the craftsmen and everybody, they all get taken off to Iraq and Persia.
这肯定比占领意大利某些地方作为凯旋更算是一个巨大的挫折，你觉得呢？是的，绝对是的。这是一种羞辱，对帝国的经济是毁灭性的打击。是的。第三大城市被攻占，所有技术娴熟的人、所有工匠和所有人，都被带到了伊拉克和波斯。
The city is stripped bare. Yeah, it's complete humiliation and a disaster. And as if one disaster like that wasn't enough. We are a year away from the arrival in, I think it's first detected in Egypt. So we talked about this with Kyle last week. So it comes to the plague arrives, hits Pelusium, hits Alexandria, winnows out from Alexandria to Constantinople and then to Italy and then onwards, westwards and eastwards.
这座城市被洗劫一空。是的，这是彻底的羞辱和灾难。仿佛这样的一场灾难还不够。我们距离大瘟疫抵达——我想它最早是在埃及被发现的。所以我们上周和凯尔讨论过这个问题。所以瘟疫爆发了，袭击了培鲁喜安，袭击了亚历山大，从亚历山大蔓延到君士坦丁堡，然后到意大利，然后继续向西和向东。
So it hits Persia as well. Absolute disaster. I mean, there is much debate about the scale of it, but I think we're with Petereter saris on this aren't we that yeah that it's so this is a disaster on the scale of the black death pretty much so so procopius says i mean obviously we did talk about this in our podcast with car harbour but just to kind of recapitulate um for for those people who missed it i mean procopius says 10 000 people a day died in constantinople and because Procopius clearly tends to exaggerate,
所以它也袭击了波斯。绝对的灾难。我的意思是，关于它的规模有很多争论，但我认为我们是站在彼得·萨里斯这一边的，对吧？是的，这是一场堪比黑死病的灾难，差不多就是这样。所以——普罗科匹乌斯说——我的意思是，我们在与卡尔·哈伯的播客中当然讨论过这一点，但为了给那些错过的人总结一下，普罗科匹乌斯说君士坦丁堡每天有10,000人死亡，由于
and because he also did think Justinian's head floated off its body and could reappear, so people sort of say, oh, 10,000, it couldn't have been 10,000. It probably means it was 500. But I think a lot of historians now would say, I mean, you mentioned Peter Sarris, who's written articles about this. A lot of historians now would say Procopius is probably right. It probably does kill thousands of people a day. It probably kills tens of millions of people
普罗科匹乌斯显然倾向于夸大，而且他还认为查士丁尼的脑袋会从身体上浮起来并且会重新出现，所以人们会说：“哦，10,000人，不可能有10,000人。”这可能意味着它是500人。但我认为现在的许多历史学家会说——你提到了彼得·萨里斯，他写过关于这方面的文章——现在的许多历史学家会说普罗科匹乌斯可能是对的。它可能确实每天杀死成千上万的人。它可能杀死了数千万的人，
across the Mediterranean. Justinian himself gets it and is one of the few that survives. So many people are dying in the streets of Constantinople that they start chucking them in the harbour and then it just blocks up the harbour because it's just floating with corpses. So Justinian orders that they should dig pits on the other side of the Golden Horn, so across from the kind of promontory on which Constantinople was built. And they dig these pits and they chuck the bodies in.
遍及整个地中海。查士丁尼自己也感染了，并且是极少数幸存者之一。君士坦丁堡的街道上有太多人在死去，以至于他们开始把尸体扔进港口，然后港口就被堵塞了，因为它到处都是漂浮的尸体。因此查士丁尼下令在金角湾的另一侧——也就是跨过君士坦丁堡建立的那座岬角对面——挖掘深坑。他们挖了这些深坑，把尸体扔进去。
And there are these hideous descriptions of how the corpses kind of melt and come to constitute a kind of corpse custard, I suppose. A corpse custard, Tom. A thick gravy. So that if somebody falls into it, they get kind of sucked down into the mulch of it and drown. I mean, it's so hideous.
这里有一些可怕的描述，关于尸体是如何融化并最终构成一种类似尸体蛋羹的东西，我想是的。尸体蛋羹，汤姆。浓郁的肉汁。以至于如果有人掉进去，他们就会被吸进腐殖质中并溺死。我的意思是，太可怕了。
If you're going to drown, don't drown in human gravy. No, I mean mean it's so hideous i mean and and so if you're gonna drown don't drown in human gravy no i mean it's really horrible and when um and when you when you get chroniclers kind of saying as one does that the whole of humanity came close to annihilation of course that's an exaggeration so people say that kind of language it's bread of the bible you know it's it's the well it's equivalent for kind of you know a daily mail headline yoy terrible for house prices all this kind of thing there's absolutely let me just be absolutely clear in case anybody's listening in uh rothermere towers there's absolutely nothing wrong with daily mail headlines they are very measured and sober and i want to go on absolutely on record as distancing myself from that shame shameful remark so if the daily
如果你要溺水，千万不要溺死在人类的肉汁里。不，我的意思是，这太可怕了。如果我们要溺水，千万别在人类的肉汁里溺水。不，我的意思是，这真的很可怕。当——当历史学家们说——就像人们经常说的那样——全人类险些灭绝，当然这是夸大其词，所以人们说这种语言，它是圣经的源泉，你知道的，这——这就好比是《每日邮报》的头条新闻：“天哪，这对房价太可怕了”之类的话。绝对有——让我绝对明确地说，以防有人在罗瑟米尔大厦收听，每日邮报的头条新闻绝对没有什么问题，它们非常克制和清醒，我要公开记录在案，与那个可耻的言论划清界限。
mail is around it would say it would say this is going to be terrible for house prices. But I think it is, you know, the apocalyptic quality of it is really very, very profound. And I think that it essentially, it's an absolute disaster for Justinian and his plans, because what it does is that it demolishes his tax base. Yes. And it means that the funds to pay his armies, to maintain the roads, to maintain the fortifications that of the empire because it means that,
所以如果《每日邮报》在的话，它会说，它会说这对房价来说将是可怕的。但我认为，你知道的，它的末日般的特质确实非常、非常深刻。我认为这本质上对查士丁尼和他的计划来说是一场绝对的灾难，因为这做的是摧毁了他的税基。是的。这意味着支付军队薪饷、维护道路、维护帝国防御工事的资金——因为这意味着，
you know, nomads are likelier to escape the impact of the plague. It's urban centres that are being hit by it. And that is in the very long run, you know, that's very bad news because it means that the Arabs will be able to move in. But in the short term, it means that bands of horsemen are able to cross the Danube you know rather as the lamb long paths do going into italy and they discover that there's no one to stop them just on um on on justinian in the play tom justinian is ill for weeks and he almost dies uh he is now he's not a young man he became emperor when he was in his 40s uh so now he is what he's in his um he must be nearly 60 yeah he's
你知道，游牧民更有可能逃脱瘟疫的影响。受到打击的是城市中心。从长远来看，你知道，这是一个非常坏的消息，因为这意味着阿拉伯人将能够搬进来。但从短期来看，这意味着成群的骑手能够越过“多瑙河”（译注：原文如此），你知道的，就像伦巴第人进入意大利那样，他们发现没有人能阻止他们。关于——关于查士丁尼和瘟疫，汤姆，查士丁尼病了好几个星期，他差点死去。他现在——他已经不再年轻了，他在40多岁时当上皇帝——所以现在他——他大概在……他一定快60岁了。是的，他正在变老。
getting on um so he's lucky to to pull through and there's obviously must have been talk when he's lying in you know who's going to be next who's going to succeed him and clearly he has one general who's a sort of dashing swashbbuckling general, very good at fighting hooligans in stadiums, but also very good at beating vandals and giving them sponges, and that is Belisarius. And it's about this point, isn't it, that you start to really notice that his favourite general, you know, they're no longer on such great terms, and that probably Justinian is worried that Belisarius wants to replace him,
所以他很幸运能挺过去。当他躺在病榻上时，肯定有人在讨论——谁将是下一个？谁将接替他？显然他有一位将领，一位风度翩翩、豪迈潇洒的将领，非常擅长在体育场里打击流氓，但也非常擅长击败汪达尔人并给他们海绵，那就是贝利撒留。正是在这个时候，不是吗？你开始真正注意到他最喜欢的将领——你知道，他们不再处于那么好的关系中了，而且查士丁尼可能担心贝利撒留想取代他，
that he's a focus for opposition, that let's get rid of the old man and get the young guy in. And do you think that Justinian's near-death experience is one of the things that explains their falling out that Robert Graves writes about in his novel? I doubt it. You don't think so? No, I think Justinian was a naturally suspicious person.
担心他是反对派的焦点，让我们除掉老家伙，换上年轻人。你认为查士丁尼濒死的经历是罗伯特·格雷夫斯在他的小说中写到的他们反目的原因之一吗？我怀疑。你认为不是吗？不，我认为查士丁尼天生就是一个多疑的人。
So down on Justinian, Tom. Very bad. Very bad. Well, I mean, he was a disaster. I mean, he was a disaster. And I think that that actually, I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we should end this account of his reign and that of Theodora by looking at the death of Theodora,
你对查士丁尼太苛刻了，汤姆。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。好吧，我的意思是，他是一场灾难。我的意思是，他是一场灾难。我认为实际上——我认为我们应该在这个时候休息一下。当我们回来时，我们应该通过回顾狄奥多拉的死、
looking at the last years of Justinian's rule, and then looking at Procopius and saying, well, you know, where is his secret history coming from? Okay, very good. We will see you after the break. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
回顾查士丁尼统治的最后几年，然后审视普罗科匹乌斯，并说：“好吧，你知道，他的秘史是从哪里来的？”来结束对他的统治以及狄奥多拉统治的叙述。好的，非常好。我们休息后见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的娱乐》
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻评论、
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com this man was both an evildoer and easily led into evil the sort of person whom they call a moral
少许演艺界八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，
pervert never of his own accord speaking the truth to those with whom he conversed but having a deceitful and crafty intent behind every word he was was insincere, crafty, hypocritical, dissembling his anger, double-dealing, clever, a perfect artist in acting out an opinion which he pretended to hold, and even then able to produce tears, not from joy or sorrow, but contriving them for the occasion, according to the needs of the moment, always playing false. So that's one of the members of our Rest Is History Club talking about my
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。这个人既是个作恶者又容易受诱惑作恶，正是那种他们称之为道德
co-presenter, Tom Holland. And if you too want to join the Rest Is History Club, join up at restishistorypod.com. So no other podcast, I think, in the world, Tom, uses the words of the historian Procopius to recruit supporters for their own podcast club. So I think that's something that distinguishes us from other history podcasts. Yes, and continuing that Procopian tradition of one minute being all smiles and nice and kind and generous and then suddenly stabbing me in the back. Well, you know what Procopius said?
畸形的人，从不主动对与他交谈的人说真话，而是在每句话背后都有欺骗和狡猾的意图。他不够真诚、狡猾、虚伪，掩饰自己的怒火，两面三派，精明，是一个极其擅长假装持有某种观点的表演艺术家，甚至能在此时此地流下眼泪，不是出于喜悦或悲伤，而是根据当时的需求为场合而捏造眼泪，总是虚伪行事。这就是我们《历史的余烬》俱乐部的一位会员在谈论我的
Very, very Procopian behaviour. He was a fickle friend, a truiceless enemy, an ardent devotee of assassination and of robbery. There was no robbery in the Rest is History Club. Let's be absolutely clear about that. Right, Tom, the lessons of history. So we've done the plague. We have done the incredibly gruelling campaign in Italy, which has been grinding all this time. We've done the fact that Justinian has suffered this terrible, devastating humiliation of the sack of Antioch by the Persians. And Theodora in all this, I mean,
联合主持人汤姆·霍兰。如果你也想加入《历史的余烬》俱乐部，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。所以我想，世界上没有第二个播客，汤姆，会使用历史学家普罗科匹乌斯的话来为他们自己的播客俱乐部招募支持者。所以我认为这是我们将自己与其他历史播客区分开来的一个特点。是的，并且延续了普罗科匹乌斯那种上一分钟还满脸笑容、温和善良、慷慨大方，然后突然从背后捅我一刀的传统。好吧，你知道普罗科匹乌斯是怎么说的吗？
she's sort of like a lot of women in history. She's invisible to the chroniclers if they're not slagging her off, isn't she? But we kind of know one thing about her, which is that she, I mean, Procopius basically says he presents in a very bad light. She clearly tried to rehabilitate lots of prostitutes. So she housed them in a convent. Procopius basically says... Yes, called repentance. She incarcerated these ladies of the night against their will, this dreadful harridan. But clearly, there's a kind of Gladstonian way of looking at that.
非常、非常普罗科匹乌斯式的行为。他是一个反复无常的朋友，一个绝不妥协的敌人，一个暗杀和抢劫的热烈崇拜者。《历史的余烬》俱乐部里可没有抢劫。让我们对此绝对明确。好了，汤姆，历史的教训。所以我们讲了瘟疫。我们讲了在意大利极其残酷的战役，这场战役一直磨折到现在。我们讲了查士丁尼遭受了波斯人洗劫安条克这样可怕的、毁灭性的羞辱。而这一切之中的狄奥多拉——我的意思是，
Yeah, completely. Completely. And she kind of makes Justinian into a rather improbable feminist. So he introduces a lot of legislation to kind of improve women's lives. Clearly, clearly influenced by Theodora. Divorce reform, mothers getting custody, the end of the death penalty for women who've been accused of being unfaithful. The death penalty for rape he brings in. So lots of things that clearly, you know,
她有点像历史上的许多女性。如果编年史家不是在痛骂她，她在编年史中就是隐形的，不是吗？但我们对她了解一件事，那就是她——我的意思是，普罗科匹乌斯基本上说——他把她描绘得很糟糕。她显然试图让许多妓女改邪归正。所以她把她们安置在一个修道院里。普罗科匹乌斯基本上说……是的，名叫悔罪。她违背意愿将这些风尘女子监禁起来，这个可怕的悍妇。但显然，有一种格莱斯顿式的眼光来看待这件事。
you have this image of this sort of Bill and Hillary Clinton kind of relationship. And she also has the latitude to support bishops and missionaries and things with her own kind of monophysite beliefs, doesn't she? So she clearly is a... Although the Orthodox tradition comes to be that that actually she was orthodox all along and that she was a kind of um trojan horse so is that how she was able to become a saint basically it is yes yeah but do you think tom that uh i mean do you think she was as it were a saintly figure i mean should you remember her as a i always think that about people who are
完全是。完全是。而且她把查士丁尼变成了一个相当不可思议的女权主义者。因此，他引入了许多立法来改善妇女的生活。显然，显然受到了狄奥多拉的影响。离婚改革、母亲获得抚养权、废除对被指控不忠的女性的死刑。他引入了强奸罪的死刑。所以有很多事情显然，你知道，
described as as being saintly by hagiographers um and the temptation is always to say it was all just a sham it was all just a fraud i i have no doubt that um theodora's you know her process of being born again if you want to put it like that in alexandria as a young woman when she turns her back on her previous career i'm'm sure that's absolutely authentic. And the obvious reason for thinking that is that Justinian, whatever else you may say about him, is he's not a hypocrite. He really does believe what he says he believes. And his Christian faith is crucially, crucially important to him. And so it's inconceivable that he would marry and love a woman who was a dissembler. Right. Because there's nothing in it for him in
你会对这种比尔和希拉里·克林顿式的关系有这种印象。而且她也有自主权，可以用她自己的基督一性论信仰去支持主教和传教士之类的人，不是吗？所以她显然是一个……尽管正统传统后来变成：实际上她一直都是正统派，而且她是一种特洛伊木马。所以这就是她如何能够成为圣徒的吗？基本上是的。但是你认为呢，汤姆——我的意思是，你认为她是一个——怎么说呢——圣洁的人物吗？我的意思是，你应该把她记为一个……我总是对那些被圣徒传记作家描述为圣洁的人有这种看法，
marrying her. I mean, he actually has to, I mean, as we discussed in a previous podcast, his uncle has to change the law to allow him to marry beneath his station. So they are a great Christian couple. I mean, no question about that. What one might say, Tom, is if she does have this shady past, which we'll come to in a second, the allegations against her, if she does have this very shady past, then it's all the more impressive that she devotes her energies to rehabilitating girls who've been sex slaves,
而诱惑总是说这一切都只是个骗局，这一切都只是一场欺诈。我毫不怀疑——狄奥多拉的，你知道的——她重生的过程，如果你想这么说的话，作为年轻女性在亚历山大，当她背叛她以前的职业时——我确信那是绝对真实的。这么想的一个显而易见的原因是，查士丁尼，无论你对他有什么其他看法，他都不是一个伪君子。他确实相信他所说的话。他的基督教信仰对她来说至关重要、极其重要。因此，他不可能娶一个虚伪的女人并爱上她。对吧？因为娶她对他没有任何好处。
girls who've been prostitutes. Yeah. Because, of course, that draws attention to her. I mean, she's not afraid to draw attention to her past, is she? Because she's not trying to distance herself. So Procopius says, and there's, I think, no reason to doubt it, because there is a Monophysite bishop who refers to Theodora without any kind of, you know, just absolutely naturally that Theodora, who was in the brothel, who was in a brothel. So it's not something that the monophysites who see her as her great champion are trying to hide they acknowledge it um and they see it as redounding to her credit so we mentioned mary magdalene that this is an example but if we if you
我的意思是，他实际上必须——正如我们在之前的播客中所讨论的那样，他的叔叔不得不修改法律以允许他迎娶门第低微的女子。所以他们是一对伟大的基督教夫妇。我的意思是，毫无疑问。人们可能会说，汤姆，如果她确实有这段我们稍后会谈到的阴暗过去、对她的指控——如果她确实有这段非常阴暗的过去，那么她将精力投入到帮助那些曾沦为性奴、
and it's so difficult because to to get into the minds of people from from such a distant culture such a distant time but that opening passage that we read in the very first, you know, the opening of part one. The geese. The geese. That passage has always been a subject of kind of, you know, titillation and salaciousness. But what her career there, she is a child.
曾沦为妓女的女孩改过自新上，就更令人印象深刻了。是的。因为，当然，这会吸引人们对她的注意。我的意思是，她并不害怕吸引人们对她过去的注意，不是吗？因为她并没有试图与过去保持距离。所以普罗科匹乌斯说——而且我认为没有理由怀疑这一点，因为有一个基督一性论的主教提到了狄奥多拉，没有任何那种——你知道的，就是绝对自然地提到“狄奥多拉，她曾身处妓院，曾身处妓院”。所以这不是那些将她视为伟大捍卫者的基督一性论者试图隐瞒的事情，他们承认这一点，
So she's a child. She's being introduced, you know, she's performing these acts as a child and she's starting to be prostituted as as you know by our standards underage well there's descriptions of her i mean i mean procopius is completely upfront about that he says uh she was too immature to sleep with a man or to have intercourse like a woman, but she acted as might a male prostitute to satisfy those dregs of humanity, slaves though they were, who followed their master to the theatre and there took the opportunity to indulge in such bestial practices. He's telling that story
并且认为这为她增添了光彩。所以我们提到了抹大拉的玛丽亚，这是一个例子。但是如果你——这太难以进入来自这样一个遥远文化、这样一个遥远时代的人们的思想了，但我们在第一部分的最开始读到的那段开头的段落——那些鹅。那些鹅。这段话一直是某种猎奇和好色主题的对象。但她的职业生涯——她是个孩子。
to say how degenerate she is. Of course, we read that story and we say, oh my God, she is a child sex slave. And so Procopius, with that kind of language, is doing what Roman moralists have always done, which is to blame the victims of prostitution and slavery for the crimes that are forced on them, the rapes that are forced on them. And to say, well, they love it. They enjoy it. They're absolutely rapacious. They're insatiable yeah that's an absolute you know so in that sense procopius as in so many other things is an absolute traditionalist and i think that it is not um it's not anachronistic to adopt a perspective that said that says well you know that is a crime because our perspective is the christ perspective, essentially, that every individual should have bodily integrity. And so I think there is a sense
来形容她有多么堕落。当然，我们读到这个故事时，会觉得，天哪，她是一个儿童性奴。因此，普罗科匹厄斯用这种语言做着罗马道德家们一直在做的事情，那就是把卖淫和奴役的受害者归咎于强加给她们的罪行，强加给她们的强奸。然后说，哦，她们喜欢这样。她们很享受。她们绝对是贪婪的，无餍的。是的，这绝对是……所以在某种意义上，普罗科匹厄斯和许多其他事情一样，是一个绝对的传统主义者。而且我认为，采纳这样一种观点并不是不合时宜的，这种观点认为，你知道，那是一种犯罪，因为我们的观点本质上是基督徒的观点，即每个人都应该拥有身体完整性。所以我认为在某种意义上
in which Theodora is, you know, her Christianity is the way that she tries to reform prostitutes, that she tries to bring in laws that will better patrol the right of women not to be raped. It's a part of this process that Justinian is also very much the embodiment of, where traditions that have been inherited from Rome are starting to be swept away by an increasingly Christian worldview. Yeah. In the sense that she's not trying to distract attention from her sin. She knows she's been a sinner, as it were, but she's also been a victim and she's not afraid. As you've often said about Christianity, the great innovation of Christianity is that there is, as it were,
西奥多拉……你知道，她的基督教信仰是她试图改造妓女的方式，是她试图引入法律以更好地维护女性免受强奸权利的方式。这是查士丁尼也极力体现的这个过程的一部分，在这个过程中，从罗马继承下来的传统开始被日益基督教化的世界观所冲垮。是的。从某种意义上说，她并不是在试图分散人们对她罪孽的注意力。她知道自己曾是个罪人，可以说是这样，但她也曾是个受害者，而且她并不害怕。正如你经常谈到基督教的那样，基督教伟大的创新在于，可以说是……
dignity and holiness in suffering, in being a victim, which the Romans had never believed, had they? And all of this brings us to the question of, I mean, she dies, poor Theodora. She dies of probably, I mean, I don't know where people get this from, where they guess how people died, but everything you ever read says she probably died of cancer in 548. So she died at the age of, in her late 40s, probably. And there was a church in which Constantine and other emperors had been buried.
在苦难中、在作为受害者中存在着尊严和神圣，这是罗马人从未相信过的，不是吗？所有这一切都把我们带到了这样一个问题，我是说，她去世了，可怜的西奥多拉。她去世的原因大概是……我是说，我不知道人们是从哪里知道这些的，他们怎么能猜出人们是怎么死的，但你读到的所有资料都说她很可能在548年死于癌症。所以她去世时大概40多岁，处于40多岁的末期。当时有一座教堂，君士坦丁和其他皇帝曾被埋葬在那里。
And Justinian, in his grief, builds a new kind of mausoleum in which she's laid and whenever he rode past it he would stop and light candles before her her grave so it was his bereavement was clearly very real um theodora was clearly you know to the end of their days they loved each other i think i did again i don't think it's being sentimental or anachronistic to say that. And she was clearly, you know, the great partner that he'd missed terribly in the kind of rather grim final years of his life. But the sort of tragedy for her, Tom, is that everybody remembers. I mean, those people who do remember her, remember her for the geese and they remember the, and that's Procopius. Now he was, to explain to who he was, he was basically Belisarius' secretary. Is that right?
查士丁尼在悲痛之中，建造了一种新的陵墓，将她安葬在那里。每当他骑马经过时，都会停下来在她的墓前点燃蜡烛。所以他的丧亲之痛显然非常真实。西奥多拉显然……你知道，直到他们生命的尽头，他们都深爱着对方，我认为……我还是认为，这样说并不是多愁善感或不合时宜。而且她显然是……你知道，在他生命中相当严酷的最后几年里，他深深怀念的伟大的伴侣。但对她来说，汤姆，某种悲剧在于每个人都记得。我是说，那些确实记得她的人，记住她是因为鹅，记住她是因为……那是普罗科匹厄斯。现在他……为了解释他是谁，他基本上是贝利撒里的秘书。是这样吗？
Yeah, pretty much. So he's from Palestine. He sees, you know, a lot of what he's describing. And as well as the secret history, he also writes a book about the monuments that Justinian raises. With a brilliant title, On Buildings. On Buildings. And he writes a history of the monuments that Justinian raises. With a brilliant title, On Buildings. On Buildings. And he writes a history of the war.
对，差不多。所以他来自巴勒斯坦。他亲眼目睹了他所描述的很多事情。除了《秘史》之外，他还写了一本关于查士丁尼建造的纪念碑的书。书名很精彩，叫《建筑》。《建筑》。他写了一本关于查士丁尼建造的纪念碑的历史书。书名很精彩，叫《建筑》。《建筑》。他还写了一部战争史。
So he writes a history of the North African War, the Vandal War, and the conquest of Italy, in which he is very, very respectful of Justinian. There's none of the stuff about moral perversion or demons' heads and shapeless masses of flesh in that. Yeah. And so in these histories of the Italian wars, he gives Justinian a very good spin. So he says of Justinian that he took over the state when it was much harassed by disorder.
所以他写了一部关于北非战争、汪达尔战争和征服意大利的战争史，在这部书中他对查士丁尼非常非常尊敬。里面没有那些关于道德沦丧、恶魔头颅和无定形血肉团块的东西。是的。所以在这些关于意大利战争的历史中，他对查士丁尼做了非常好的粉饰。所以他谈到查士丁尼时说，他在国家饱受混乱困扰时接管了政权。
And his achievement was that not only did he make it greater in extent, but also much more illustrious. So in the history of the wars, Procopius is the spokesman for Justinianic propaganda. Yeah. And so the question has always been, what on earth is he doing? One of the great kind of literary assassinations of all time. So that, as you said, when everyone people think of Theodora, they don't think of the same. They think of the they think of literary assassinations of all time. So that, as you said, whenever people think of Theodora, they don't think of the saint. They think of the geese.
他的成就是，不仅使国家的疆域更加辽阔，而且更加名声显赫。所以在战争史中，普罗科匹厄斯是查士丁尼宣传的代言人。是的。所以问题一直是，他到底在搞什么鬼？这是有史以来最伟大的文坛谋杀案之一。所以正如你所说，当人们想起西奥多拉时，他们想到的不是圣人，他们想到的是……这是有史以来最伟大的文坛谋杀案之一。所以正如你所说，每当人们想起西奥多拉，他们想到的不是圣人，他们想到的是鹅。
Yeah, and the gymnastics. But isn't this simply, I mean, very easily explained, that Justinian and Theodora have fallen out with Belisarius and his wife, Antonina. There's all kinds of weird stuff about Theodora and Antonina kind of plotting against each other and gossiping and all this sort of, um,
还有体操。但这难道不是……非常容易解释吗，查士丁尼和西奥多拉与贝利撒里乌斯及其妻子安东尼娜闹翻了。这里面有各种关于西奥多拉和安东尼娜互相密谋、说长道短的诡异事情，所有这些……
sort of very Rebecca Vardy and Colleen Rooney. And, um, and the Procopius is writing because he's, you know, he's Belisarius, he's partisan. But he's not,
有点像丽贝卡·瓦迪（Rebecca Vardy）和科琳·鲁尼（Coleen Rooney）那种风格。而且，普罗科匹厄斯之所以写这些，是因为他……你知道，他是贝利撒里乌斯的人，他有党派偏见。但他不是……
he's equally rude about Belisarius. It's just bitter, isn't he? He's just generally bitter. I mean, he's, he's slagging them off as well. I think,
他对贝利撒里乌斯同样刻薄。他只是满腹怨恨，不是吗？他只是整体上充满怨恨。我是说，他也在痛骂他们。我想，
so I think, I think what is going on is that procopius is is a conservative and essentially you know that is what romans were you know i mean it's insane to talk about roman conservatives because everyone is conservative everyone had this kind of deep-seated assumption that the old ways were the best um justinian again is is christian to the extent that he's dreaming of a new and better world. It's a new and better world in which he is the autocrat, but he is a radical.
所以我认为，普罗科匹厄斯之所以这么做，是因为他是个保守派，本质上你知道，罗马人就是这样（你知道，谈论罗马保守派简直是疯了，因为每个人都是保守派，每个人都有这种根深蒂固的假设，认为老方法才是最好的）。查士丁尼同样具有基督教色彩，他梦想着一个崭新且更好的世界。这是一个崭新且更好的世界，在其中他是独裁者，但他是一个激进分子。
He is a revolutionary to that extent. He wants to reshape the world, even if he's saying, well, by, by reshaping the world and improving it, I'm also, you know, restoring and repairing also restoring and repairing what's gone wrong. And Procopius, in The Secret History, the thing he goes on and on and on about is that Justinian is constantly, he's deliberately setting out to mess everything up. This is what's giving him his great source of pleasure. He's going around ruining everything, changing everything, messing everything up. And I think for Procopius, genuinely, he thinks that Justinian is a demonic figure because he can't really understand ultimately, firstly, how he's mind, is that although we said that the history of the wars is much more overtly positive, there's a passage where the Goths send ambassadors to
从这个角度讲，他是一个革命者。他想要重塑世界，哪怕他说，好吧，通过重塑世界并改善它，我同时也是在……你知道，在恢复和修复，同时也在恢复和修复出错的事情。而普罗科匹厄斯在《秘史》中，喋喋不休、翻来覆去念叨的一点就是，查士丁尼一直在蓄意要把一切都搞砸。这就是他快乐的巨大源泉。他到处毁掉一切，改变一切，把一切都搞得一团糟。我认为对于普罗科匹厄斯来说，他是真诚地认为查士丁尼是一个恶魔般的人物，因为他最终无法真正理解，首先，他的心思……虽然我们说过战争史明显更具正面色彩，但其中有一段是哥特人派遣大使去……
Cusro, the king of Persia, to try and persuade him to launch an invasion of the Roman Empire while the Romans are busy invading Italy. And the Gothic ambassador says of Justinian that he is a man who by nature strives for change and loves was to not belong to him at all. He was not able to keep things as they are. He was therefore tried to seize the whole earth and has been captured by the desire to take for himself each and every rule. And you compared Justinian to Khrushchev. I mean, that is, you know, the Goths there are kind of casting Justinian as an agent of universal change and revolution and upheaval.
波斯国王霍斯劳（Cusro），试图说服他趁罗马人正忙于侵略意大利时，对罗马帝国发动入侵。哥特大使这样评价查士丁尼：他是一个天生渴望改变、热爱并不真正属于他自己的东西的人。他无法保持现状。因此，他试图夺取整个世界，并被占有每一个统治权的欲望所俘获。而你把查士丁尼比作赫鲁晓夫。我的意思是，你知道，那里的哥特人实际上把查士丁尼塑造为一个全球性变革、革命和剧变的代理人。
And I think that Procopius is putting in the Gothic ambassador's mouth what he feels about Justinian. Yeah, that sounds very plausible. I think he genuinely does see him as a demonic figure. Even though, of course, the irony is that Justinian. Yeah, that sounds very causal. I think he genuinely does see him as a demonic figure. Even though, of course, the irony is that Justinian thinks he is reviving the glory of Rome. So what to some people seems a radical project, and you could argue, I mean, we'll come to this in a second,
我认为普罗科匹厄斯是将他对查士丁尼的感受放到了哥特大使的口中。是的，听起来非常合理。我想他确实真心实意地把查士丁尼看作一个恶魔般的人物。尽管当然，讽刺的是，查士丁尼……是的，听起来很有因果关系。我想他真心实意地把查士丁尼看作一个恶魔般的人物。尽管当然，讽刺的是，查士丁尼认为自己在重振罗马的荣耀。所以，在某些人看来这是一个激进的计划，你可能会说——我们稍后会谈到这一点——
you could argue is a moment of tremendous disruption from which the Roman world never recovers. Justinian conceives of that as a restorative. That's why some historians talk about this as a reconquista. Even though actually it's a good analogy because, of course, the reconquista is not really a reconquest because those territories never belonged to Spain. So Justinian's so-called reconquista probably doesn't seem like a reconquest
你可能会说这是一个巨大的颠覆时刻，罗马世界自此再也没有恢复过来。查士丁尼却将此视为一种复兴。这就是为什么有些历史学家将此称为“光复运动”（reconquista）。尽管实际上这是一个很好的类比，因为“光复运动”并不是真正的光复，因为这些领土从未属于过西班牙。所以查士丁尼所谓的光复运动，在……
to people in Italy who'd probably much rather be off living under the Goths without armies trudging over their farmland. Justinian is doing it for what he sees as the very noblest of motives. He's doing it as a Roman and he's doing it as Christian. And he sees these are the duties that have been laid on him by God. Where Procopius is, I think, scabrously unfair to Justinian is in saying that Justinian is doing it just for the fun of it. So Procopius says of Justinian that he wasn't satisfied just with ruining the Roman Empire. So in other words, the territories that he already owned, and that this is why he insisted on invading North Africa, why he insists on invading
意大利人看来，可能并不像什么光复，他们大概宁愿在没有军队践踏农田的情况下生活在哥特人的统治下。查士丁尼这样做是出于他自己认为最高尚的动机。他是作为一个罗马人这样做的，也是作为一个基督徒这样做的。他认为这些是上帝赋予他的职责。普罗科匹厄斯对查士丁尼刻薄且极不公平的地方在于，他说查士丁尼这样做只是为了好玩。所以普罗科匹厄斯说查士丁尼并不满足于仅仅毁灭罗马帝国——换句话说，就是他已经拥有的领土——这就是为什么他坚持入侵北非，为什么他坚持入侵……
Italy. It's for the sole purpose of ensuring that he can destroy the inhabitants of those lands, as well as the inhabitants of the Roman Empire. It's just a ludicrous thing to say. But I think probably Procopius genuinely believes that. The forces of evil have been unleashed on the earth. And again, I think that the scale of the plague and the war of the age is so monstrous
意大利。其唯一目的就是确保他能够消灭这些土地的居民，以及罗马帝国其他地方的居民。这简直是荒谬之言。但我认为普罗科匹厄斯可能真的对此深信不疑。邪恶的力量已经被释放到大地上。同样，我认为瘟疫的规模和那个时代的战争是如此骇人听闻……
that I think, you know, this is an age where you're living in apocalyptic times. I mean, Justinian, so Theodora died in 548. Justinian, although he's a fair bit older than her, he lives for another 17 years,
以至于我认为，你知道，这是一个生活在末日时代的时代。我是说，查士丁尼……所以西奥多拉死于548年。查士丁尼虽然比她大不少，但他又多活了17年。
which I think, you know, when historians talk about it he he feels like an aging exhausted everything's a bit grayer i mean obviously it's not surprising it feels like a sort of grayer time because it's in the aftermath of this horrendous plague um constant sort of fighting it's very clear isn't it tom that he's you know their tax base has shrunk their manpower has shrunk they're struggling to fight off incursions on the frontiers. So at one point, there's a group called the Kutrigers, who make it all the way down into Greece, sort of charging around Greece, you know, sort of sacking and pillaging. And you've also got the first rumors of a group of
我认为，当历史学家谈到这一点时，他感觉像是一个老去、精疲力竭的人，一切都变得黯淡无光。当然，这并不令人意外，感觉像是一个更加黯淡的时代，因为这是在这场可怕的瘟疫以及持续不断的战斗之后……很明显，对吧，汤姆，他们的税收基础缩水了，人力缩, 了，他们在艰难地抵御边境的入侵。所以有一次，有一群被称为库特里格尔人（Kutrigers）的部落，一直深入到希腊境内，在希腊四处冲杀，进行洗劫和掠夺。你还听到了第一批关于一个叫做……
people called the Avars, who are going to be a issue um for constantinople in the long run so it's quite a sort of grim gray story isn't it there it really is and i think that that it is a genuinely tragic story if by tragedy you mean you know someone is destroyed by his own qualities and virtues well let's get to it so justinian dies in november uh 565 He'd ruled for almost 40 years. He's succeeded by his nephew, Justin, who becomes Justin II. And then you have a couple more emperors before you really get to the kind of, as it were, the cataclysm. Yeah. Yeah.
阿瓦尔人（Avars）的群体的谣言，他们长远来看将成为君士坦丁堡的一个问题。所以这是一个相当阴暗黯淡的故事，对吧？确实如此。而且我认为，这是一个真正悲剧性的故事，如果悲剧的意思是——你知道——一个人被他自己的品质和美德所毁灭。好吧，让我们言归正传。所以查士丁尼于565年11月去世。他统治了近40年。他的侄子查士（Justin）继位，成为了查士丁尼二世（注：实为查士丁二世）。然后又经历了几个皇帝，才真正迎来某种大灾难。是的。是的。
So to sort of jump ahead and anticipate, to paint the picture for people who are not massively familiar with this. At the end of the 6th century, beginning of the 7th century, the Roman-Persian conflict becomes this kind of all-out superpower death match where the Persians appear to have the Romans completely on the ropes and a new emperor called Heraclius sort of summons up every last sinew of Roman energy and fights them off. And they're both absolutely exhausted. And it's at this point that the Arabs appear and just absolutely wipe the floor with it. And people who want to know what happens then, we have done an episode on Muhammad, which I commend to you.
所以为了跳跃到前面并做个前瞻，为那些对此不太熟悉的人描绘一下图景。在6世纪末、7世纪初，罗马与波斯的冲突演变成了一场全方位的超级大国生死决斗，波斯人似乎把罗马人逼入了绝境，而一个名叫希拉克略（Heraclius）的新皇帝凝聚了罗马人所有的精力和力量将他们击退。结果双方都精疲力竭。正是在这个时候，阿拉伯人出现了，并将他们彻底横扫。那些想知道接下来发生什么的人，我们做过一期关于穆罕默德的节目，我向大家推荐。
So, Tom, if you want to follow this story up, that's the next stage in this story. So, Tom, there are two ways of looking at Justinianian and theodore and their their time in that light i would say one would be to say this is the last hurrah for a particular kind of rome before the deluge and the and to say you know what there's quite a big interval between justinian's death and the coming of islam it's ridiculously unfair to blame him for something that happens so long afterwards. He did his best to restore the Roman state. It's not massively unstable. I mean, I know it's fiscally fragile, but it's not massively unstable when he dies.
所以，汤姆，如果你想继续了解这个故事，这就是这个故事的下一阶段。那么，汤姆，从那种光亮来看，看待查士丁尼、西奥多拉以及他们的时代有两种方式。一种可以说是，这是大洪水到来之前，某种特定罗马形式的最后狂欢。并且可以说，你知道吗，从查士丁尼去世到伊斯兰教兴起之间有相当长的一段时间，把这么久以后才发生的事情归咎于他，是极其不公平的。他尽最大努力恢复了罗马国家。它并不是极度不稳定的——我是说，我知道它在财政上很脆弱，但在他去世时，它并不是极度不稳定的。
Actually, he is a pretty great emperor. He reasserts the dignity of the office. He reasserts the authority of the capital, reasserts the authority of the capital all of those things that's one interpretation the other interpretation would be to say he massively overextends the empire he wastes a lot of money on campaigns in north africa and italy that don't really achieve anything it takes 20 years to subdue italy um you know he because of the overextension in the long run he lands his successes with commitments that are unsustainable.
实际上，他是一位相当伟大的皇帝。他重振了这一职位的尊严，重振了首都的权威，重振了首都的权威……所有这些，这是一种解释。另一种解释会认为，他极大地过度扩张了帝国，在北非和意大利的战事上浪费了大量金钱，而这些战事并没有真正取得什么成果。他花了20年时间才征服意大利……你知道，由于长期的过度扩张，他给继任者留下了不可持续的承诺。
And it's basically his fault that it all goes wrong a generation later. I'm guessing that you're in the first camp. No, I'm not. I think his campaigns in Italy are disastrous, as I said, for anything that would rank as a kind of the continuity of Roman civilization in Italy. Yeah. I think it's that they are so destructive, but I think the real villain isn't Justinian.
一代人之后一切都崩溃了，这基本上是他的错。我猜你属于第一阵营。不，我不是。我认为他在意大利的战役是灾难性的，正如我所说，对于任何可以被视作罗马文明在意大利延续的事物来说都是如此。是的。我认为它们太具破坏力了，但我认为真正的罪魁祸首不是查士丁尼。
I think it's Yersinia Pestis, which is why I wanted to do this in the wake of the, the discussion that we had with Karl Harper. So by that you mean the plague. I mean the plague. So I, the, I think that without the plague,
我认为是鼠疫杆菌（Yersinia Pestis），这就是为什么我想在与卡尔·哈珀（Karl Harper）讨论之后做这个节目的原因。你的意思是瘟疫。我指的是瘟疫。所以，我认为如果没有瘟疫，
I think it is entirely possible to see the situation in Italy, stabilizing Roman military power in Italy becoming sufficient that the Lombards never invade, the Danube frontier holds, Antioch has been demolished by Khosrow, but this has happened before. Antioch is always being demolished either by Persians or by earthquakes. So that frontier could be stabilized and you would never have had, you know, because the whole reason, the whole thing of why the plague is so devastating relative to nomads is that it's urban centers that get destroyed and people out in the desert, you know, are able to maintain their forces. It's that that ultimately in the long run kind
我认为完全有可能看到意大利的局势稳定下来，意大利的罗马军事力量变得足够强大，以至于伦巴第人从未入侵，多瑙河边境得以坚守，安条克虽被霍斯劳摧毁，但这以前也发生过。安条克总是被波斯人或地震摧毁。所以那个边境本可以稳定下来，你也绝不会经历……因为瘟疫相对于游牧民族之所以如此具有破坏性的全部原因、整件事情在于，遭到摧毁的是城市中心，而在沙漠中生活的人们……你知道，能够维持他们的军队。正是这一点最终从长远来看……
of dooms the Roman control of Syria, of Palestine, of Egypt. So I think without the plague, well, I mean, maybe the Roman Empire would still be a going concern. Who knows? But I think the reputation of Justinian would be very different. And I think that he could have spent his last decades rather than frantically struggling to repair the damage inflicted by the plague, in restoring prosperity to Italy, restabilizing the frontier along with Mesopotamia. I think the story would have been very different. And I think the Balkan frontier wouldn't have collapsed as it does. You wouldn't have had barbarians kind of penetrating all the way to Greece, all the way to the walls of Constantinople. I think the story would have been very different.
注定了罗马对叙利亚、巴勒斯坦和埃及的控制。所以我认为如果没有瘟疫，好吧，我是说，也许罗马帝国仍然是一个正常运转的实体。谁知道呢？但我认为查士丁尼的声誉会大不相同。而且我认为，他可以把最后的几十年花在恢复意大利的繁荣、与美索不达米亚一起重新稳定边境上，而不是拼命挣扎着去修复瘟疫造成的破坏。我认为故事会完全不同。而且我认为巴尔干边境也不会像后来那样崩溃。你不会看到蛮族一路渗透到希腊，渗透到君士坦丁堡的城墙下。我认为故事会完全不同。
And with Italy stabilized, of course, the Romans would then be in a position to start thinking about recapturing maybe Southern Gaul, the Provincia, you know, very kind of Romanized area and expanding the toeholds that they do get in Southern Spain. So I think the story could have been very different. I think, you know, it's right to call the plague that hits the Mediterranean in the 6th century the Justinianic plague because he is the paradigmatic ruler of the age. But it's also kind of, you know, it's a cruel irony because it is the Justinianic plague that destroys Justinian's legacy. Although, as it stands, Tom, he leaves a not unimpressive legacy. I mean, he codifies the laws.
随着意大利的稳定，当然，罗马人就会处于这样一种位置：开始考虑重新征夺或许南高卢、普罗旺斯（Provincia）——你知道，一个非常罗马化的地区——并扩大他们在西班牙南部获得的立足点。所以我认为故事本可以截然不同。我认为，你知道，把6世纪袭击地中海的瘟疫称为查士丁尼瘟疫是正确的，因为他是那个时代的典范统治者。但这也是一种……你知道，这是一个残酷的讽刺，因为正是查士丁尼瘟疫摧毁了查士丁尼的遗产。尽管就目前而言，汤姆，他留下的遗产并非微不足道。我是说，他编纂了法律。
He doesn't see… Hagia Sophia, the architecture of… He leaves the most famous… I mean, his reign leaves these tremendous buildings, the mosaics, the art. He doesn't see… You know, there's not massive civil wars and rebellions during his reign. I mean, the riots… Apart from the Nica riot. There's not massive civil wars and rebellions during his reign. Apart from the Nica riot.
他没有看到……圣索菲亚大教堂，建筑……他留下了最著名的……我是说，他的统治留下了这些宏伟的建筑、马赛克、艺术。他没有看到……你知道，在他的统治期间没有发生大规模的内战和叛乱。我是说，骚乱……除了尼卡暴动（Nica riot）。在他的统治期间没有发生大规模的内战和叛乱。除了尼卡暴动。
Right, the riot in the Hippodrome is very famous, but by the standards of Roman rebellions, it's all done and dusted in what, a week? And limited to the capital. So you could say of the Roman emperors in this period, he is by far the most... Visionary. The most visionary, the most adept at using the machinery government. The one who has...
对，赛马场的暴动非常有名，但以罗马叛乱的标准来看，在一周内就全部平息了。并且局限于首都。所以你可以说，在这一时期的罗马皇帝中，他是最具……富有远见的。最具远见的，最善于利用国家机器的。那个拥有……
Visionary is the right word. The one who has the clearest vision for a renovated and reformed, modernized empire. And it doesn't work through factors that he can't control. I think, though, the tragedy is that vision runs into the greatest natural calamity to hit the Mediterranean. And that's why I think it was right to do these series of episodes because they have been prefaced by that episode we did with Karl Harper on the way that plague impacted the Roman world.
富有远见是正确的词。那个对翻新、改革、现代化的帝国有着最清晰愿景的人。而这一切之所以没有成功，是因为受到了他无法控制的因素的影响。不过我认为，悲剧在于，这种愿景遭遇了袭击地中海的最大自然灾难。这就是为什么我认为做这一系列节目是正确的，因为它们是以我们与卡尔·哈珀（Karl Harper）关于瘟疫如何冲击罗马世界的节目作为前言的。
We've talked ever since we started this whole podcast, The Rest is History, about the Byzantine Empire and Byzantium. Do you think this is the moment at which it no longer makes sense for us as historians looking back to talk about Rome? So in other words, is the word Roman still useful to describe the people who call themselves Romans in the 7th, 8th, 9th, 10th centuries? Or do you think Justinian's reign and the period that then immediately follows it marks such a break that they're no longer usefully Romans? I think a more useful point is the Arab invasions and conquests. Because I think what had been the Roman Empire basically gets reduced to a rump.
自从我们开始这个播客节目《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History）以来，我们一直在谈论拜占庭帝国和拜占庭。你认为这就是那个时刻吗？对于我们这些回顾历史的历史学家来说，继续谈论罗马已经不再合理了？换句话说，“罗马人”这个词是否仍然可以用来描述那些在7、8、9、10世纪自称为罗马人的人？还是你认为查士丁尼的统治以及紧随其后的时期标志着如此巨大的断裂，以至于他们不再能被合理地称为罗马人？我认为一个更合理的转折点是阿拉伯人的入侵和征服。因为我认为曾经的罗马帝国基本上缩水成了一个残存的躯壳。
You know, that great legacy of cities that the emperors in Constantinople had inherited from the Greek and the Roman classical worlds, they get destroyed essentially. So all that really gets left is Constantinople. And the people of Constantinople did call themselves Byzantine. So they called themselves Roman, they were Romeo, but they did also call themselves Byzantines. The extent that what had been the Roman Empire, you know, at one point, basically, is Constantinople with a few kind of scattered territories that are constantly being invaded by Arabs and barbarians from the north. I think the Byzantine conveys the sense of a really radical break. I think that Justinian's rule is very decisive as a kind of fracture point, but it's a kind of evolution of norms in Rome that someone like Procopius can see as a kind of shocking assault. But Procopius is kind of talking about it as a political process. What happens with the Arab invasions is almost the entire collapse of the empire. And essentially, the effort of ensuring
你知道，君士坦丁堡的皇帝们从希腊和罗马古典世界继承下来的伟大的城市遗产，基本上都被摧毁了。所以真正剩下的只有君士坦丁堡。而君士坦丁堡的人民确实自称为拜占庭人。所以他们自称为罗马人，他们是罗马人（Romeo），但他们也确实自称为拜占庭人。曾经的罗马帝国……在某种程度上，基本上就是君士坦丁堡加上一些零星的领土，这些领土不断受到来自北方的阿拉伯人和蛮人的入侵。“拜占庭”这个词传达了一种真正激进断裂的感觉。我认为查士丁尼的统治作为一种断裂点是非常具有决定性的，但它是罗马规范的一种演变，以至于像普罗科匹厄斯这样的人可以将其视为一种令人震惊的攻击。但普罗科匹厄斯是在将其作为一种政治过程来谈论。而阿拉伯人入侵带来的几乎是帝国的全面崩溃。并且本质上，确保……
that Constantinople doesn't fall, that something in Anatolia, in Greece, in the Balkans, and to a degree in Italy is preserved, is so shattering and exhausting that by the time the Byzantine empire starts to get back on a moderately stable footing, everything has changed. And you have people in Constantinople who look at what has remained of the Roman era, you know, the statues, the friezes, even the statue, great statue of Justinian that he's put up to himself. And they can't remember what, you know, who or what these things are. They think that they're kind of illustrations of necromancers or, and there are no histories. That's the other thing.
君士坦丁堡不陷落，确保安纳托利亚、希腊、巴尔干以及在某种程度上意大利的某些东西得以保存的努力，是如此令人粉碎和精疲力竭，以至于当拜占庭帝国开始恢复到适度稳定的基础时，一切都变了。君士坦丁堡的人们看着罗马时代的遗存——你知道的，雕像、浮雕，甚至是他为自己竖立的查士丁尼大雕像——却记不起这些东西是谁或是什么了。他们认为这些是某种巫师的图解，而且没有任何历史记录。这就是另一回事了。
So Procopius is kind of the last of that living tradition that reaches all the way back to Thucydides and Herodotus. But it's the measure of the, you know, we took, again, we talked about this with Karl Harper. I think it's a measure of the trauma
所以普罗科匹厄斯可以说是直溯到修昔底德和希罗多德的那种活的传统的最后一人。但这正是……我们再次与卡尔·哈珀谈到过这一点，我认为这正是……他们所遭受的创伤的尺度，
that they suffer, that people aren't around to write histories. So there really is a break, I think. Well, and I think we should do future episodes on the Arab conquests and Byzantium's resilience and, of course, iconoclasm, which is a particularly mysterious and intriguing moment in Byzantine history. Quite topical. Very topical.
人们不在身边书写历史。所以我认为确实存在一个断裂。好吧，我认为我们应该就阿拉伯人的征服、拜占庭的韧性以及当然还有圣像破坏运动（iconoclasm）制作未来的节目，这是拜占庭历史中一个特别神秘且引人入胜的时刻。非常具有时效性。非常具有时效性。
And on current form, Tom, we'll probably get around to doing those in about 2027. Yes. We'll see you in 2027. But there's one last question before we end, which I think is the question that will have been on a lot of listeners' minds since we started the first of these Justina and Theodora podcasts, what seems like an eternity ago. And that is this. Tom, do you think Theodora was a justified um victor of love island i really do i really do and i think that um uh so love island in britain finished last week um i could imagine love island finished about a month ago um so theodora is a kind of love island contestant
按照目前的进度，汤姆，我们大概会在2027年左右完成这些节目。是的。我们2027年见。但在结束之前还有一个问题，我认为这个问题自我们开始第一期查士丁尼和西奥多拉播客以来——感觉像是一个永恒前——就一直盘旋在许多听众的心头。问题是这样的。汤姆，你认为西奥多拉是《爱情岛》（Love Island）实至名归的……呃……爱情冠军吗？我真的这么认为，我真的这么认为。我认为，呃……所以英国的《爱情岛》上周刚结束……我能想象《爱情岛》大约在一个月前结束……所以西奥多拉就像是一个《爱情岛》的参赛选手，
who then ends up the most powerful woman in Britain. Yeah. That gives you some measure, I think, of her quality. The most powerful woman in Britain. Yeah. I see you're saying that's the analogy. Imagine that. And you, I think, have some sense of the fact that clearly she combined charisma, sex appeal, intelligence, ruthlessness, and ultimately holiness in a
最后却成了英国最有权势的女人。是的。我认为这在某种程度上衡量了她的品质。英国最有权势的女人。是的。我明白你的意思，这就是这个类比。想象一下。而且我认为你隐约感觉到，显然她将个人魅力、性感、智慧、冷酷无情以及最终的神圣性完美地结合在了一个……
package that I think is entirely inimitable. Well, I'll end it with this thought, Tom, that if Theodora had been married to Stanley Baldwin, her co-champion on Love Island, rather than Justinian, Stanley Baldwin's mantra, of course, was safety first. And it may well be that the Roman Empire would still be going today had stanley baldwin been in charge in the sixth century and that is a thought you probably won't have heard in any rival history podcast but i imagine we'll live with our listeners till the end of their days if only if only it had been stanley and theodora yeah if only stanley baldwin had been roman emperor in 527 history would be very different. And on that bombshell, thank you,
我认为无与伦比的组合中。好吧，汤姆，我用这个想法来结束：如果西奥多拉嫁给斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）——她在《爱情岛》上的联合冠军——而不是查士丁尼，斯坦利·鲍德温的座右铭当然是安全第一。如果6世纪由斯坦利·鲍德温掌权，罗马帝国今天可能还在运行，这是一个你在任何竞争对手的历史播客中都可能听不到的想法，但我想它会伴随我们的听众直到生命的尽头。如果当初……如果当初是斯坦利和西奥多拉就好了。是的，如果斯坦利·鲍德温在527年成为罗马皇帝，历史将会截然不同。带着这个重磅炸弹，谢谢你，
Tom. That was an absolutely splendid. I really enjoyed that. I don't know if our listeners enjoyed it, but I certainly enjoyed it. And we will see you next time for all kinds of treats. What have we got coming, Tom?
汤姆。这绝对是一场精彩的对话。我真的很享受。我不知道我们的听众是否喜欢，但我绝对乐在其中。我们下次将为大家带来各种精彩内容。汤姆，我们接下来有什么节目？
We've got lady Jane gray. We've got, we've got the real outbreak of the first of the second world war. coming, Tom? We've got Lady Jane Grey. We've got... We've got the real outbreak of the Second World War, haven't we? We've got holidays. Yeah. Holidays.
我们有简·格雷夫人（Lady Jane Grey）。我们有……我们有第二次世界大战真正的爆发，对吧？我们有假期。是的。假期。
Lots to come. Roman holidays, Victorian holidays, since it is the holiday season. And looking further forward, we've got Walt Disney and we've got French films and we've got the Norse myths.
精彩内容不断。既然是假期季节，有罗马假期，维多利亚假期。再往远看，我们有华特·迪士尼（Walt Disney），有法国电影，还有北欧神话。
History of France told through 10 french films yeah so lots to come all sorts of delights uh and we will see you then bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
通过10部法国电影讲述法国历史。是的，所以精彩内容不断，各种乐趣。我们到时见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加长版节目以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。